I met jiff about 15 years ago and you
know took me about school and and showed
me and my family we went through it and
and he showed me what he was doing and
there's so much that I could describe
about that that basically meant that he
took responsibility for their lives in a
hundred square blocks of Harlem right in
the center of Harlem he takes
responsibility for the lives in
partnership with Stan Druckenmiller a
great philanthropist and a partner they
all decided that they're going to do
this thing so a very big audacious goal
of taking responsibility for their lives
because if you get to know that
community and what it's like it is not
just a matter of going to school it is a
matter of the total what you know the
parents the shootings the issues that
all of that that ends up being the
traumas that are there total lives that
they don't have the benefit of dealing
with so he took hundred square blocks of
Harlem and whatever and he described
what he was doing and he demonstrated
what he's doing which was basically to
take care of their lives and he said it
was I think he described it as like a 16
year plan that he said I'll take him
right from the beginning and then we'll
take him through that and that'll be
their community and then they will go to
college and because it's their community
they will come back and they will be
doctors and they will be lawyers in that
community and they will be part of that
and that's not wasn't just his vision
that was the reality that he actually
delivered you know and I and my family
and I related very much to this and so
he he and I became friends over this
period of time I'll just go you know
quick story because it's just so many
stories take you forward and I said this
man this man is a shaper we have a kick
together we enjoy each other but week
but but this man is a shaper okay what I
mean by a shaper is somebody who can
visualize and then build out that
reality a unique reality and this man's
a shaper so you might find in in my book
I was I said okay I want to find a shape
or
how do I find a shaper so I gave shaper
tests to you know what are the
psychological profiles of Jeff Canada
Bill Gates Elon Musk Muhammad Yunus in
different areas cause he's a shaper
he's a demonstrated shaper so and I
watched that and over that period of
time kind of evolved over my wife
started about ten years ago to get
involved with the same population in
Connecticut of going to that those
schools and dealing with that population
and as a result you know I'd come home
at the dinner table every night and she
would describe the circumstances that
they're dealing with and we will go into
that but they're unimaginable
circumstances mostly you don't know
those circumstances even though they're
right around the corner like you go for
ten minutes away and you can come into
Bridgeport or a town like that and you
don't see those circumstances and those
circumstances include abject poverty
shoot shootings gangs things that you
would never let the no society no civil
society would let that fall below that
kind of level anyway I would hear that
on a regular basis and I would I got
deeply involved and so and we've been
you know in this talking about this and
what we want to do together so that's a
little bit of background I don't want to
take too much time but I wanted to just
give you a little bit of framing this
man is a shaper so I'd like to I'd like
you to know a little bit if we can come
out of here with what I'd like to
accomplish I'd like you to know a little
bit about the man and the shaper and and
I'd like you to also know a little bit
more about the circumstances the general
circumstances and I'd like to look them
beyond those general circumstances to
say okay what do we all do about that or
do you know didn't ignore it so a little
bit about the man is and and why he's a
hero and and by the way I would say you
don't know the heroic ISM that a lot of
the successful people who have come
through this these communities what what
real heroes are in in in his case his
dad left him when he was something like
four and he was lucky enough to have a
great mom
and then through that guidance and so on
he had his evolution we're gonna we're
gonna touch on that in a minute
and I'm lucky enough also to know a
number of other people like I said I
know Sean Combs Diddy and he is a hero
of mine and we don't we might not think
of these peoples here they're the
greatest years because they have had to
overcome the greatest obstacles and and
have gotten there and developed the
greatest character to to then do great
and generous things to to help other
people so I want you to get to know Jeff
a little bit then I want us to go into
what the community is like in the
circumstances that are being faced there
and then I want to go back to what what
to do about so so Jeff let's go into
your story okay you tell it yeah your
dad left it yeah good I'll go you tell
it right so I mean look so one of the
things that I'm obsessed with is this
issue of how you can be in America you
can be a good person god-fearing care
about your community do everything that
you're supposed to do to show your of
good character and have not a clue of
how folk just a short distance away are
living so it's funny wait this is when I
realized that my world had changed we
were living in the Bronx and my mother
lost her job and we lived in this nice
quiet community and we moved to a
community when you looked at we were on
a front of the building we looked out
with off a 6-story walk-up
we looked out the window at least kids
were out there and I said how is it that
your mother
her job and you actually end up in a
better community well little did I know
uh that the kids downstairs we were out
there and we were waving cuz I'm me and
I had three brothers so four of us were
in a new block and we're waving out the
window and kid looks up at us rubs his
fist in his eye and points at us and I
look at my brothers and I'm like look so
friendly and so we wait a little bit
more tentatively did exactly the same
thing and I think those kids are gonna
beat us up so then now a single mom
we're in a new place
all my brothers they look at me cuz I
had the best relationship with my mother
said you got to go tell mom so I go on
and say mom those kids want to beat us
up and so here's my mother's biggest
fear I'm raising four boys no father
we're in the in the city they have to
grow up and have independence they can't
she's like those boys aren't gonna beat
you up you are you guys are scared y'all
go down here and make friends I said to
my brother's mom ain't gonna help us
with this we got a problem and and the
deal was and the deal was before you
could come downstairs and play you had
to go fight and none of us knew how to
fight we know anything about fighting ah
but your choice was either stay in the
house or go fight so I'm trying to
figure this thing out and then this is
when it hit me that I was an alternative
universe my mom didn't make very much
money at very she sent my brother out
with $10 which was like probably 30% of
a weekly income and he was robbed in the
hallway they took the $10 and that meant
we weren't gonna be able to make it
through the week and so we called the
police and so I'm standing in the police
show up and we're explaining what
happened and just the absolute are sort
of disregard they looked at that you
called us for $10 and you expect us to
do what and I was like it fingerprints
go and do something right this is money
they made it clear they had zero
interest in helping us that we were on
our own and I realized we were on our
own with no one
protect us and I spent the next 10 years
trying to develop a set of skills that I
could protect the family yet my mother
would be walking down the street men
could say the most obscene things to her
right and she would have kids with her
and you would just sit there and you'd
want to be able to stand up and fight
when I was like eight what are you gonna
do and I just sat there saying at some
point I'm gonna get enough power to
protect my mother I wasn't interested in
any academic all kind of Paula's
interested in physical how do you go out
and physically protect yourself and I
realize young people growing up where
violence is ever-present for us to
really believe that they're going to be
able to spend time preparing
academically like kids who aren't doing
that it's just simply not true
the other part of this came out and
waiting for Superman look when Davis
Guggenheim in that documentary was
figured finished for about five months
it didn't have a name I'd call him
everything well you know what's going on
what's with the name and they were
trying to figure out what to call it and
finally he told me we're gonna call it
Waiting for Superman because they took
that from a statement I made in the film
which was true I was a huge comic book
reader only DC Comics no Marvel that's
how that's how old I am
Marvel wasn't even invented then and
when my mother I must have been about
eight or nine my mother told me there
was no Superman and I began to cry and
she thought I was crying because there's
no Easter Bunny right oh it's I was
crying because my last hope of making it
out of the South Bronx was that here was
this superhero who came in in always at
the last minute saved the good people
and when I realized there was no
superhero I knew nobody was gonna save
us in that community and people look at
me they but Jeff you got out yeah but I
had three other brothers only one of
them made it out healthy the other one
died one is still struggling my wife is
from Harlem she had four sisters and
brothers none of them made it past 25
the toll and this is the physical toll
people are on dear
but the
emotional toll do you know it's like to
lose people when you're so young and you
grow up in a world thinking you don't
know about tomorrow you don't know about
the future young people growing up in
that kind of environment have so many
things against them as you can imagine
ray I've spent the rest of my life
trying to figure out how we help those
young people make it so they can you
know live in a country that the rest of
us experience which is a great country
if you're in certain zip codes it's not
such a great country if you're another
I'm very lucky through my wife Jen's I
want to have exposure to this that we
all don't see and it's just right around
the corner and there are lists here and
and the statistics of something like
20-some odd percent I've had somebody
close to them shot or killed in Hartford
Connecticut
the capital here kids cannot go to
school walk to school without walking
through areas of gangs that they can be
shot and not my wife asks the mayor of
why can't police assure safe passage
well they only have 275 policemen
because that's all they could afford
because they I got to cut down on this
or cut down on that and something like
38 percent of them have family members
who were incarcerated mm-hmm and so and
it's all it's all of that and so when
you when I say heroism and I'd say
heroism is overcoming your obstacles and
so you look like a man like him and you
say you when you'll get to know him and
you look at that and you say that but he
was blessed he was blessed because he
had a mom who was a great mom and who
loved them who we happen to speak to
today because and when you look at that
when we look at the particular cases the
trauma I think what you need
understand and what I've come to
understand is that it's very difficult
at a very early age the trauma the
post-traumatic stress that a child
receives at a very very early age unless
they have that kind of mother so you
were lucky but tell me because now you
you have your whole population he took
responsibility for all the kids in a
hundred square blocks of Harlem tell us
more of what it's like and how you do it
so you know it's it's fascinating as you
mentioned my mother the my mother made
an investment when we were young that we
were the only kids that I knew on our
block are that mom she couldn't really
afford to do this and and but she got
the world book encyclopedias now most of
you all have no idea what that is
right but if you were growing up in the
50s are the only way you could really
get in one place everything going on in
the world was if you bought a set of
encyclopedias right it started at a and
ended at Z right aardvark was the first
thing that you ran into right and but if
you think about it today right everybody
has ten thousand times more information
on their phones when I grew up if you
didn't have access to some sort of
comprehensive set of encyclopedias you
actually didn't understand anything
about the world you were growing up
knowing nothing because of that
investment I actually had my whole world
expanded I think we were gonna go
through a twosie I think we got through
in right we never made it through the
last part because I mean they were
really full books but every time I
opened up that book I'd learned
something about a world that was not the
world I was living in in fact the one
thing I couldn't find was anything about
the world I was living in right they
didn't write about that no one published
it and so for me I began to understand
that my experience was not the
experience of lots of folks in this
country so
if you look at what we decided to do in
the why behind it my board you know
stand and and they're all numbers guys a
lot of folks from hedge funds are on the
board
and they all kept saying we just if we
got to spend money what's the most
efficient way for us to do it what years
should we invest in that's going to make
the most difference in a kid's life and
I kept looking at the research and the
more I look at the research the more it
said from birth right right through when
you get them in college and I began sit
and they were like no no no you can't do
everything Jeff you can't do everything
figure out the time period that's the
most important and this one norm for a
couple years and let me tell you how we
ended up solving this I finally got to
my board numbers and I said all right
let me turn that question around you
have kids yep
you have a spouse yo yeah we're both
college-educated you live in a nice
place wonderful and your kids go to
great schools yes when could you drop
out of their life for four years when
you're young no no God no Jeff not when
they're young you gather well how about
when they get to middle school oh my
goodness you know high school drugs and
sex and so I said so why are kids coming
from the best neighborhoods the best
families that you all afraid to go away
for a weekend right and you expect us to
drop out of our kids lives for years and
their life is going to be fine and they
said you know what I think you have a
point there is no you know the most
important time in a kid's life today
today that's when you save them you
can't decide if I do something between
zero to three their life is going to be
fine not if they're growing up in one of
these communities because there's so
many obstacles that can trip you up it's
not just academic obstacles there's the
drugs there's the crime there's the
violence this depression there's mental
health issues all of these things impact
young people in a way that interferes
with their ability to do well and we
want to celebrate the ones who get out
oh yeah look they're wonderful they went
to an Ivy League school and that's
but all I can think about all the ones
who never had a chance to get out so we
start from birth something we call baby
college we help parents understand brain
development because that stuff is real
as I tell folks
my wife Yvonne and I we have four kids
our oldest is 50 and our youngest is 22
there was like a 20-year gap at the time
we thought it was a good idea it said
around 1 days out raising those kids
that wasn't that hard you you forget why
you should have kids while you're young
but what happened during that interim is
that we found out about 0 to 3 we found
out about all that's going on in those
young brains that we didn't really
realize a lot what's happening but now
we know this toxic stress that you're
talking about it not only has impact
emotionally today the evidence it's
becoming clearer that it impacts your
physical health as you develop and as
you grow so this thing doesn't go away
so I'm thinking about all of these kids
growing up traumatized and how are we
trying to create a world for them where
they have this different set of
expectations and I just tell you one of
the things that happened so I'm with my
youngest kid he's 22 now but he was only
about 12 then and were visiting one of
our schools and every morning the kids
come up and they have to say their Creed
and the end of their Creed is I will go
to college I will succeed this is my
promise this is my Creed so here we're
in the hallway my hundreds of kids are
lined up and my young son and they're
saying as he looks at me he says dead
you're brainwashing these kids and I
said yep that's what I'm doing and so
this year at graduation a group of kids
that started with us at baby college
were graduating why it's 20 years later
they're graduating high school and they
say that same Creed that they've been
saying their whole educational
experience and indeed that's what we're
we're trying to set a set of attitudes
and beliefs that's supported by action
not just good words how do we help you
overcome these obstacles so these young
people have a shot are in our great city
in New York tremendous accomplishments
and ain't nothing in the context of the
size of the problem okay so we're we
talked about this I said okay Jeff that
was great but like how are you going to
deal with this because my we're dealing
my wife and I are dealing with
Connecticut okay so I don't know if you
know but my wife for the last ten years
has been in that community and helping
out in cheese I won't go on at length
but we've created a mission beyond what
she's doing to put will make a hundred
million dollar donation they will make a
hundred state we put together this group
of wonderful people that is bipartisan
so on to try to take on to get high
school kids who would drop out through
high school and into a job which is not
an easy thing because they not only get
them through high school but who is
their community and what's their path to
an income their community is largely can
be gangs and whatever that is and
getting a job is not like hey you can
make money other ways and he knows this
very well and so to work through that
and we that one of the reasons Jeff is
ears because we're brainstorm and I like
Jeff how do we do this thing
and so when I'm when I'm looking at that
I'd say that was unbelievable hundred
square blocks okay but that ain't
nothing in relationship to the issue
okay so we take we try to Connecticut
okay that ain't nothing yeah and then so
I was asking him okay so what are you
gonna do to have a kind of big impact
okay how do you deal with that problem
yeah so Jeff what are you going to do
so so ray-ray and I know well enough
unknown one another well enough that
what do you what he said what he said
which was yeah that was great but that
ain't nothing and not many people have
discussed my career in that way but
buddy but he's right he's right because
it's one thing if you don't know right
and there's a lot of people who don't
know they just honestly know what's
happening when you actually know what's
happening and you believe honestly
there's an answer and you don't do
everything in your power to try and
share that with this country I think
that is a huge huge error and I am
convinced on that ayat old stand I have
retired and I told him my mission is to
help at a minimum an additional million
children in this country I've reached
this next level so I was working with a
group at blue Meridian partners with
another entity you know most of the
folks on there the bombers and some of
the other folks and we were thinking
about the country and our biggest
challenge with this work so ray and
Barbara they're gonna put up a hundred
million dollars help Connecticut that is
great and one of the reasons and it's a
drop in the bucket but one of the
reasons I wanted to come here I didn't
know I was talking to you all
cuz I didn't come here to talk to you
all but that's great I'm glad you all
are here I came because because this
issue about how is it that we make this
Connecticut effort successful because
one of the things we did to Harlem
Children's Zone we proved it could be
done in a neighborhood but no one has
proved it can be done in a state and if
we're gonna scale things we've got to go
out and and show folks that these things
I'll be at but I have a real vested
interest and trying to help Barbara be
successful in what she's trying to do
but the big issue is that this should be
part of a public funding strategy so
public dollars being spent in a more
efficient and effective way delivering
at scale what we know works with kids
and the an issue came up I explained to
Ray
and I won't tell you all the insides and
outsides but Mike Bloomberg I've known
for many years when he was mayor of New
York City we did a lot of the education
reform stuff together and Mike wanted me
to help with his campaign and for lots
of reasons I didn't want to go out and
be identified with one candidate more
than another because I'm associate with
the Harlem Children's Zone and I don't
want people to think I own the
Children's Zone is playing sighs what I
thought there's one thing that would get
me to really support Mike and if that's
if he put ten billion dollars in a
federal program if he gets elected to
help us do this work around the country
so I went to Mike and I said I'm with
you if you'll do ten billion dollars in
a federal program that does these kind
of replications where we're holding
people accountable but where we're not
afraid to invest in places that's had
this massive disinvestment historically
and Mike and his team said yes so I'm
not here to do a political commercial
I'm just I just want you to know if you
see me on TV going on and on what the
deal is and I think because this has
been this has been an issue you write
you lose and I did I want to necessarily
get sold public and I won't put Mike in
a bad place but the issue the issue
since ray has mentioned it
the issue that I say when Mike was
because what happens if I do all of this
to try and help him get elected and then
he ends up dropping out or not winning
the nomination and I said with the
amount that you're willing to spend in
your influence will you back this
program win or lose this program is
directly tied to the most at-risk
communities in this country particularly
communities of color and Mike said that
he would do it win or lose that this is
something he's going to back
I guess I just did a commercial I was
trying to do a commercial
okay but that's real and you can find
you can look it up because he mentioned
it out loud in public that he was doing
this so that this is not just between us
here it is publicly out there now
raising ten billion dollars that's big
whoa well III think I think for you know
my wife who as you and Barbra know
because y'all have met her is a deeply
religious lady ah and she said to me
Jeff if you're going to do something
like this
make sure if you get what you want it's
enough and my sense is part of what a
lot of us in this space do we do
whatever we think we can afford but it
may not be enough to actually get the
job done and my belief is that this is
like this is like investing in anything
else in my opinion if you know it's
gonna take this investment to be
successful and you invest here well what
do you expect is gonna happen right it's
not gonna work and we've been doing that
in this space working in poverty for all
the years of my career people have not
been prepared to invest now part of it
is they don't believe certain things
work but once we know something Mark's
why won't we do the kind of investment
because people tend to not believe these
communities are worth that kind of an
investment and I think that's an
American yeah couple of things come to
mind
first of all you could see what what an
unbelievable man he is right and what a
really great Hera the cat the the
quality of the character and so on and I
don't think almost anybody could get
like that if they didn't have to go
through the obstacles and they didn't
have the love of the parent and the
guidance in order to do that and I want
to say like when I see when I know other
people I could say others I'd like to
bring others in here who
and so that we realize what incredible
heroes they are so that we look up to
them and some of that as the greatest
heroes and also they need heroes if that
population they need the role models
because I'm saying um in all of that
like I'm I'm saying Sean Combs say did
he same story and and and the Y
community doesn't know that and his
father was killed at - okay
he had a great mother his mother worked
three jobs had to do this and there are
many like that and you will never get
that type of character you know by
coming through a normal like let's say
okay you live in Greenwich Connecticut
you rate them you can raise good kids
but wow those are heroes right and so
they need to be recognized as heroes and
also as role models how do we do that
better I think I think you brought up
one of the issues when you think about
sort of look we're in America it's a
capitalist country it's the greatest
economic system I think ever invented
but it tends to assume that your value
is based on how much you've earned and
not necessarily what you've done in your
life right and so I think there's this
real disconnect because there are people
I mean one of the things that stunned me
and in my early heroes are the folk who
actually knew they were sacrificing
their life and they still did it anyhow
and I thought that you know dr. King and
I thought was accident they knew he got
every week he was warned they are coming
to get you they're going to kill you and
you know I tell folks one of my biggest
Harold heroes is Harriet Tubman you all
y'all know Harriet right and I tend to
think I was brave ah but the day I was
friends with Harry and she said Jeff I
got this idea
I want to go back down south uh and I'm
gonna go get some and I'm thinking
they're not just gonna kill you they're
gonna torture you too I mean like here
we write an op-ed or something Harry
do we have I like to think maybe I would
have done it once over and over so for
me there are people who have done things
in this country that just go unnoticed
because we don't put ourselves in their
place we actually don't think in that
same circumstance what I would have done
that and to me trying to live up to some
of these heroes and heroines I'll just
give you one other example that really
vexes me any if you see hidden figures
yeah now look I grew what you have to
realize I was a teenager when we were
trying to win this war to go to space do
you know what it would have done to the
black community to know these black
women were considered computers do you
know how many black students would have
majored in math if they thought they had
seen a symbol of this keeping this kind
of stuff intentionally away from a group
of people undermines their belief in
themselves you don't see the examples
that yeah okay to make that because that
is a whole thing I want to look up to
you yeah okay we're gonna go to a couple
of questions let's open it up for
questions in kind of outcome space you
talked about success in getting people
you know kids all the way through into
college a lot of the times when I start
to wrap my head around the problem that
you've tackled your whole career it
starts to feel like squeezing a balloon
because you're kind of like alright
everywhere I go there's another problem
that pops up or it's somewhere else you
have to go solve it but he talked a
little bit about how you really think
about success and what outcomes you
shoot for yep
so it's that's a great question because
I am very clear on what our outcomes are
which is kids graduating with a degree
getting connected to the labor market
the evidence of what happens to
communities when jobs disappear one of
one of the seminal books that change my
way of
thinking about this is written by I
think probably one of the greatest
sociologies happened to be
african-american William Julius Wilson
his book when work disappears talked
about what happened in Chicago when Jobs
left and there was a study that just
came out that looked at what happened
when factories closed just recently and
they were looking and guess what
happened substance abuse suicides
depression child abuse divorce all of
the stuff that became associated with
the poor in the cities african-americans
happens everywhere
folks me again the Lou's job it actually
breaks up the fabric of community
because we haven't said to people you're
something different than the job you
hold we define ourselves by what we do
and when you lose that definition you
fall prey to all the other social evils
in the world so I'm my outcomes are very
clear a kid with a degree and a decent
job that's what I care about
so do I care about third grade tests yes
but you can do great in the third grade
but that doesn't mean anything to me if
ten years from now right you're standing
on that corner right hustling and you're
not on your way going into school so
we've got about nine hundred forty of
our kids in college by eight hundred of
our kids have graduated with we're
focusing on connecting these kids with
jobs because it is like squeezing a
balloon and my board you sound like a
board member of mine for a while they
kept saying when does it end right and I
said well any when we got em in college
well guess what we looked at the data
they were dropping out of college that
no we gotta help them get through and
then we like okay you're good and then
you know what we found out you're good
but you have no contacts nobody to call
no way to figure out how to get a job an
interview and the rest of that stuff so
we said we got to do more to connect
them to this and then when they came to
me for graduate school I said hey guys
it's over all right you're done you
figure the rest of this out on your
alright you got a degree but but I'm
being I'm being serious about this to me
this is about getting a generation right
all
the set of experiences and people push
back against this College thing with me
but this is because always about 90% of
our kids to college but we get 98% of
them into college and my thing is I
don't want any kid to say I took this
job because I didn't think I was smart
getting the college just means that
you're somebody thought you were smart
enough to go to college which is just
self-definition and I think that
prepares you to think about work and not
thinking about hustling which is where a
lot of our kids to fall to when they try
and think about how am I gonna make a
living remarkably successful version of
this I want to say that from studying
these things it's like if we could just
only give like three things right the
three things is a parent or a mentor who
cares about you okay it's almost a
defining thing a good basic education
like uh you know I didn't grow and then
kind of a non-violent enough and poverty
and and trauma and the society pays an
enormous price it not only is it in just
unjust but if the society pays an
enormous price for that we're gonna go
through the accounting of it but we
really believe that the it's going to be
so profitable because the state of
Connecticut pennies six hundred million
dollars a year for incarceration costs
so when you start to take the all-in
aside from the human tragedy if you just
can deal with that
the return on investment economically
and the fairness of it we haven't talked
about how it's possible to not create an
acceptable bottom and by the way this
isn't just a black community thing this
is this goes on in education programs
the average I looked at these quartiles
quintiles top 2020 next 20% and so on
40% of the population their kids
education is five times as much money
per capita as the bottom 60% of the
population so you look at a cycle and it
really should be remediation should be
the other way in order to do it because
they would need extra to overcome so we
as a population are getting almost what
we deserve almost it's so what are your
thoughts about how that what should
happen it's fascinating because I've
been getting a lot of pushback around
the criminal justice issues on one in
supporting Mike because I've stopped and
frisked which I fussed at him for a long
time around but but part of what
happened and this is part of what was
happening people forget what was going
on during the crack epidemic that
happened in the late seventies early 80s
the murder rates were off the chart
people were trying to figure out what
we're gonna there was this belief and it
was it was just bad social science there
was a belief that what we were missing
was a get-tough approach on crime and
that was going to be the answer so we
started locking people up and we we did
so in a discriminatory fashion right so
we were locking up african-americans for
having small amounts of drugs and we
weren't even searching white Americans
so when you police is where you arrest
and no one put those two things together
and we ended up locking up hundreds of
thousands of folks for the most minor of
things and that has created I think this
huge sort of group of folks who are all
the labor roles because they've got
felony arrests and it's staggering the
numbers in particular in
african-american and Latino men I had a
situation where I knew somebody and what
he did is he came home he had a hot
temper
and didn't hit his wife yelled at his
wife neighbor said okay let's called in
the police it put had him arrested need
a calm down he couldn't go to work that
night he was working a hard worker what
you know like a shift like from 3:00 in
the morning to 10:00 in the morning or
something lost his job I mean these are
hurdles that are tough hurdles by the
way and they're the most expensive we
opted out for something and what people
always talk about what it costs to save
a kid and you know it cost us about
$3,000 on top of the school stuff or for
kids and families and people would
always argue about me about affording
that right and then I would say but you
look around the country the average
incarceration rate right nationally
about 30 percent $30,000 New York
State's about 60
you can't even I guarantee you don't
know what it costs to lock somebody up
for a year in New York City 300,000 now
I used to say 147 but what happened was
we reduced the population but it didn't
reduce the cost so now the cost per
person is skyrocketing I've heard not
one person ever say we can't lock up any
more people one of these so saving them
is not scalable
but locking them up is scalable that to
me is just bad politics it's bad science
and it's been devastating when that's
done in a way that it hits one community
poor people of color are
disproportionately because it looks like
we have a solution and there's no
solution here and we've actually done
harm in the studies that we've done in
render well I'll give you another
statistic Connecticut so you're in
Connecticut there are disengaged and
disconnected students a disk engaged
student is one who goes to school but oh
it has an absentee rate of greater than
25 percent or and it's failing classes
so school's not working for them a
disconnected student is one that they
don't know where they are they've left
the school system 22%
of the high school students in
Connecticut or one of those okay so they
they're going to be they're going to be
out on the street the economics of of
getting them in the between the eighth
and ninth years is really measured in a
few thousand dollars but the
incarceration costs are in the autumn
every year or those other numbers so how
are you profitable you have a question
yeah so Ray's talked about having to
walk by gangs in the way to school and
you've talked about having a fight in
your neighborhood how do you guys think
I mean how do you think about looking
after students when they're not in the
classroom I mean I think that's that's a
great question because that's part of
the essence of what we do our belief is
that it is the out-of-school time where
most kids get in trouble and as I've
told folks I've yet done you know hours
one of our buildings on hunt when T 5th
Street eyes yet to walk on 125th Street
and see a group of kids reading Langston
Hughes on the court just never seen it
right and so when kids are out of the
watchful eye of caring adults are they
sometimes do dumb things now if you're
19 you're here at UConn and you do
something dumb you probably over drank
maybe threw up in the wastepaper basket
said right you don't on 25th Street and
you're drunk and someone comes up with a
brilliant idea let's go rob the Chinese
restaurant and you know you do something
stupid there goes the rest of your life
right so part of this is limiting the
amount of time my kids have to do stupid
things because we're watching them and
they all know and a lot of us live in
the community so they all know we're
always looking for signs that they're
not you know living up to a set of
expectations that we have for them so I
think that's out-of-school time is
critical the programs are open in the
evenings on the weekends and the
summertime we trying to make sure that
our kids are spending more time with us
in anyplace else because look we all
grew up we all had parents
we didn't listen to everything they said
right but the big stuff we tended to
listen to right the little style yeah
maybe we did some stuff here to come
home they don't go with that person but
you know you didn't think maybe I'll get
a gun and go hold somebody up right that
wasn't in our consciousness it is with
kids who wouldn't have caring adults
around them kids do with their friends
do so if your friends are all hustling
and getting high guess what you're gonna
end up doing the pressure to do to me no
peer pressure it's gonna overwhelm most
kids so we try to create environments
where the pressure is the opposite and
that I think is all happens
out-of-school time for where most of our
kids are in our program we found
after-school programs are great because
the infrastructure is there so the kids
can just go right after and there they
get really good mentorship and guidance
so that they get good social influences
as well as then education as well as
taking them off the street after-school
programs are a big good get a big good
deal
hi I'm just curious in your program
which sounds fabulous
what are some of the other stakeholders
in that and they're thinking so I'm
thinking about the gangs the police
though especially when you first started
what were some of those obstacles and
how they feel about your program in the
middle of their community by the way I'm
gonna tell you I'm gonna interrupt you
for a minute
somebody some only he could because I
want to tell he took his school he built
his school right in the middle of the
projects in this spot and the goodness
that radiates from that school is an
impact as a possum pressive thing to
watch but go ahead I just wanted you to
know that and we realized that was a
better story to tell them the one I was
going to tell that's gonna go right to
ray from now on so this is this is part
of this is historical right so there's
business historical problem that African
Americans have had with the police
departments right and its history and in
Harlem in particular there was a group
there was something called the dirty
thirty xxx precent was right in the
middle of Harlem it was so corrupt that
everybody knew they were in league with
the drug dealers so the last person you
would call if you had a problem what's
going to be the police because they were
with the criminals now when we started
our effort they decided to clean out
that entire precinct and they replaced
all of those that's a big news story and
everything they replaced them with folks
who actually were honest police officers
and they came to community we want to
help no one believed them no one trusted
them and so we couldn't we couldn't have
Harlem change if there wasn't actually
adequate policing going on so we were
the intermediaries with the police
department community members would talk
to us we talked to the police and then
they would see and then after a while
they began to talk to the police
themselves because part of the issue was
folks in Harlem thought there was this
really sophisticated network of
criminals where they were smart they
were talking to one
saying Jeff fizzle it wasn't truly a
bunch of knucklehead kids right every
now and then they would accidentally
find out something that was an issue but
we watched that whole situation turn on
its head when now we have a really
decent relationship with the police
because they know here's the other issue
they know that our kids are kids who are
all on the right path so there's this
whole group of kids over that maybe a
Harlem Children's Zone kid and we know
they're trying to get the right thing so
it's not like the problem is solved for
all the black people in Harlem but it
certainly has improved but this issue
ray talks about it's one that I think is
important and one of the most important
things we're gonna do for this country
the housing projects have always be even
in Harlem the worst outcomes for our
kids and families were in the housing
projects the most crime a family of four
had was living on about $18,000 a year
which is New York City it's just like
unbelievable about 62 percent of the
folks had no working adult in the home
so we decided we wanted to build our
brand-new school right in the middle of
that housing project and it was
controversial the community summit of
residence one of the council people they
were against charter schools and they
made a big deal about it and what we had
said to focus we're building this for
you they didn't believe us
even me they didn't believe me you're
not gonna build a one hundred million
dollar building for us and they fought
us and the biggest my biggest opponent
this woman who lived in the housing
projects and everywhere we were going
all the things this lady would say to me
I would tell you I had to tell my staff
I know y'all think I'm special but I'm
not gonna be special in this meeting
when this woman gets a hold of me right
and she she taught me down the day we
opened that school and I showed all the
kids from the housing project who were
in the school she came up to me
afterwards and she said mr. Canada You
Know Who I am
the yeah I know who you are she says I
want to apologize she says I was wrong
my grandson was walking past a school
and he told his older cousin
who were like 18 and 19 I'm going to
that school when it opens and they were
like no you're not don't say that that
kid not just school and she said they
never thought anybody would open up a
school in the housing projects for us
and my grandson's in this school right
now and I you know what I recognized in
these communities there's a reason
people are suspicious their reasoning
they're hostile there's a reason they
think people are going to take advantage
of them because that's been their
experience and if you're doing the right
thing and I tell folks don't think
people are gonna applaud and say how
wonderful you are because there's a lot
of suspicion right about what your
motives are and why you're doing stuff
and I tell folk who often think oh you
know it's gonna be tougher for me
because I'm white I look at my wife with
some Harlem I lived in Harlem with it I
didn't mean nothing anybody they thought
this was some attempt to exploit them
and even after we had spent 15 years
demonstrating other words people were
still suspicious about this so the
person who stood up to all the community
folks was the tenant president of Saint
Nicholas houses she understood why we
were doing this and she just said to
everybody wait to see what happens I'm
telling you you can trust these guys
they're doing that for our kids so now
no one knows that history anymore
building's been open five or six years
everybody's there for Thanksgiving we do
a big Thanksgiving dinner for the
community and we do nice things around
Christmas and the holidays everybody's
like oh they're wonderful they're
wonderful they didn't think that when
this thing was happening but that's just
part of the challenges I think of
working in communities and I have said
to folks I'm sure ray and Barbara faces
for every person who thinks you're doing
something good there's a person who
hasn't believed that you're doing
something that's selfish and just in
your own interest and they're being used
and exploited and there's nothing you
can almost say to change that until they
see the proof and I kept telling my team
it's not until this building is open and
folks come in that they're actually
going to believe us up until then we're
just going to take the sort of anger
that they're bringing towards us as a
cost of doing business yeah like a
Barbara's case it's taken two ten years
of being
in the community knowing the people
doing that the builds trust
so everybody bipartisan you know but
still it takes education because that's
absolutely right
you know anyway the what occurs to me is
we must find a way to take whoever here
wants to go either to Harlem Children's
Zone or to go down to Bridgeport or
whatever and to show them what our what
would our neighbor or what it is and
what's going on the thing that I have
found and I absolutely believe that
until you see it you don't really get it
that's all that folk come in and I talk
about what we're doing here I go yeah I
love it I love it I look every single
time they walk in and they say oh now I
really understand right now I really got
it right so I just think if you care
about these issues
I think one of the most important things
that happened from our work before we
said we were going to try and now you
have to remember the old Harlem a 30% of
the buildings were abandoned graffiti
everywhere trash all over the streets
open-air drug markets everywhere we said
we're gonna change this community and
people then believe you could do such a
thing they just simply didn't believe it
now gentrification has a different set
of challenges right when that happened
but nobody ever thought Harlem could be
gentrified it was like Detroit it was
like new walk it was like all of these
places that have been crumbling for
decades and one of the things that we
want to say to folks is it is doable
it is not easy it's not everybody can't
do it but it is doable and those who can
do it need to do it in places if you
care about this country and you believe
in America Esther says in theory that's
what this country stands for we have to
turn that theory into fact and this is
how I believe you can do it at scale
well you can see why this man is a hero
of mine right and as a hero should be
here of everybody and just recognized so
you know like we're waiting for Superman
you are our Superman man so thank you
very much
[Applause]